welcome to this video I'm playing big
age what the heck is that song pierre
and miquelon and that's exotic produce
some small island ok so let's let's see
Kings Indian or I could also go do that
let's go d 5 boon fault yeah this is how
I played it back when I'm regularly
employed this in tournament chess night
a 396 night see for Bishop e6 this I've
played a number of times even once in
1997 when I played the open tournament
in Groningen in the netherlands i had
the opportunity to play this is black
against the legendary tony mild who
sadly passed away only three or four
years later I think he died in two
thousand one or two thousand not quite
sure and I lost the lost a good game
against him played two played it very
well not sure that this is in the
database even cannot recall it seeing it
in the database um okay but what is he
doing here yeah if you play C for you
sometimes some people take it it's even
in the Queens gambit you can take it I
is busy looking up the theory grabbing
his ave rock book 1 d4 only to discover
that I've rock is not even having the
sinister book okay I found it 93 is the
right one
I'm just making funny I mean I don't
really think people look up the lines
those kind of weird process it can mean
all kinds of stuff even-even a bathroom
break happen so happens all the time
okay so mm-hmm he's just a centralizing
pieces not too bad policy a5 this is
designed to gain a bit of space on the
queenside maybe a for even and let's see
one interesting idea in this position
would be to take on c6 and sacrifice the
exchange then 95 it could be a good idea
yeah maybe hmm get that I'm not really
sure about hmm interesting yeah it runs
into things like 94 night b4 and and
stuff like that even 94 as a move 94 94
Bishop g2 that be4 as a move but c7 is
hanging and I have always had bishop if
I'm between and take a 2 is also
possibility mmm not sure I can also
consider to take on f3 and then okay
let's let's do that i mean just before
i'm going forward time loss here let's
let's play with this some intends to
take on FY Nandi 410 spaceship a night
before on day to pawn ok aqui but he
can't play and he can just play that
he's got Queen B 1 okay
okay so i could take on a tool attacking
the rook yeah i probably had something
better but at least i'm i'm good in
terms of the time i came what I was
thinking is that i can maybe give up be
seven for the pawns him come on push
they push the pawns i'm not sure about
it this being objectively of the best
but it is dangerous with those advanced
pawns supported by in the night and
possibly the bishop
Oh interesting
hmm ok I'm going to take that but now
what's what am i doing now interesting
okay grab this and now look a five maybe
rook bhi Scott Bishop c6 and I'm not I
ok I can play a three takes be three
okay yeah yeah I actually believed be
three would be good I'm tending a three
takes Knight c3 now the pants are really
dangerous maybe the computer finds
something but yeah winning now it was a
very dangerous configuration not sure
about the objective merit but it's very
dangerous white resigned yeah i don't i
don't really know here it's a
interesting what is the computer giving
yeah it gives a white a very clutch oh
but it's going down yeah it's it it's
interesting i believe at least we played
this one and hear what sorts of the
computer is going down and down in it c
1 and tier yeah equal equal hard to
believe maybe it's equal I mean hard to
believe mean meaning that it did it
feels like it should be good for
somebody not equal but sometimes there
are Perpetual's and stuff this now I
don't know he needs to be very precise I
actually thought it was lost already but
rook be one rupee wonders a code
ludie to defense it's a very very cute
line look at this yeah and hey I wind up
in the bishop now because of this
multiple threat here here needs to check
check and this is assessed as equal by
the computer chair maybe this is very
very tricky and then a blitz game of
course add this is losing out right so
he must play a rupee one okay
interesting he got into a bit of trouble
because of this time spent tried one
move yeah maybe he was distracted by
something alright thanks for watching